- [Narrator] This pretty
lady's name is Asterix.
And this is her son, Nate.
They are northern white-cheeked gibbons.
Their species is critically endangered.
Only about 1,000 of them
are left in the world.
These gibbons are found
in Vietnam and Laos.
They were also once
found in southern China,
but are thought to be extinct there
due to logging of the gibbons' habitat.
Asterix and Nate mainly eat fruit.
But Asterix has a sweet
tooth for dandelions.
Infants are pale at birth
and turn black as they age.
Female gibbons will change color again
as they near sexual maturity.
Becoming golden or a deep red.
Males remain black.
Gibbons are known as small apes
because of their slight stature.
These primates have long arms,
which are much longer than their legs.
And they are muscular with
strong thighs and shoulders
to help them swing through trees.
The speed and agility of this species
has earned them the reputation
as the trapeze artists
of the animal kingdom.
This is the northern white-cheeked gibbon.